hey weebs dear volo here and in today's
video we're going to go over the
abilities
power appearance and personality of
probably in my opinion one of the
coolest and most mysterious characters
that we have met in the jujutsu kaizen
manga so far this is
toji fujigodo but before we get into all
that remember to hear about that like
button if you enjoy the video and leave
a comment down below with who you'd like
to see in the next character analysis
if you're new around here be sure to
subscribe for similar content to do with
juju kaizen yasuke
and more anime hopefully in the future
anyway let's get into the appearance
of the goat toji for shiguro he was a
former member of the xenon family
and an infamous assassin known as the
sorcerer killer
toji is a muscular man with straight
black hair that reaches to his ears he
has green eyes like his son
thin black eyebrows and a sharp scar
over the right side of his mouth
just at the edge of his lip toji wears a
simple outfit consisting of a long
sleeve
and matching pants with sandals while
fighting toji wears a tight-fitting
short sleeve shirt and sports tan baggy
training pants with a black belt weave
through the waist as well as black
martial art slippers
the personality of toji fushogudo toji
is a cold calm
confident type of man who likes to enjoy
himself and make money using his skills
he appears to enjoy insightful
conversations with others as long as it
somehow relates to himself
and can trade banter with the highly
sarcastic likes of satoru gojo
upon meeting gojo asked if they had met
before but toji assured him that he's
not the type to remember some guy
either in battle toji has a crazed
expression as if he's lost in the
sensation of the fight but he's always
maintaining
a cool and calculated head constantly
plotting his next move
toji is an assassin who's garnered the
name sorcerer killer and spends his time
gambling between assignments from shady
clients a lot like maymay he doesn't
ever question the client's motives as
long as the money is right which is why
he ended up taking such a ridiculous job
from the time vessel association
he married a woman and left her just as
quickly leaving his newborn child
without knowing their gender and
eventually forgot their name this just
happened to be megami
toji even planned on selling megami to
the xenon family that he had left behind
exploiting the young megamie for the
cursed technique he would eventually
inherit
as a non-sorcerer raised in the xenon
family who values curse techniques above
all
toji is just another man who has
suffered due to the interest of the
sorcerer clan in a very similar manner
to maki zening
his evil actions are a result of his
dejection towards the jujutsu world as
he attempts to spite it
born without curse energy toji
eventually left the xenon family and
married a woman
taking her name for shiguro he sold
their son to the zenin family because he
believed in young megami's potential to
be a real sorcerer naming him megami
because it means blessings
toji was able to complete his final
mission for the time vessel association
and should have cut and run when faced
with a rejuvenated sadhuru gojo
however judah was disdained for the
jujutsu world and sorcerer families toji
chose to try and cut down the most
gifted sorcerer in the world as another
way to spite them all
unfortunately this pride cost toji his
life unable to look past his demons he
deviated from his natural instincts and
looked past the uneasiness plaguing him
during the fight
keeping up with his cold persona toji
chose not to assa
any final words at first in his final
moments he thought of his ex-wife and
the son so he decided to tell sedero
that he would be sold into the xenon
family in a few years
a decision that would eventually lead to
sataru becoming a close mentor for
megami in the future as well as granting
megami a chance to work as a jujutsu
sorcerer granny ogami's science
technique returned togi's soul from the
dead
turning him into a manifestation of
carnage he would attack anything in his
path
mostly focused on crushing the strongest
opponent available
while endangering his own son with his
outburst of aggression toji chose to
return to death by committing suicide in
order to protect him he also did so
without ever revealing their connection
to each other
instead with his final words toji
expressed that he is glad to hear that
megami refers to himself as a fushigoro
instead of a zening the overall power of
toji for shigeru
while toji is technically a non-cursed
user with no innate talent for jujutsu
he was one of the most elite fighters in
the jujutsu world when he was alive with
innate physical prowess far superior to
all others in his path
toji contended with the most dangerous
and highly ranked jiu jitsu
practitioners this era had to offer
he was able to defeat special great jiu
jitsu users on three separate occasions
one of which was a young sataru-gojo who
at the time was still considered a
prodigy and one of the world's strongest
sorcerers
the other sorcerer who was considered
the strongest at the time was the cursed
manipulator suguru ghetto who was
effortlessly taken down by toji
along with several of his strongest
curse spirits toji referred to sugeru's
abilities as rebel compared to his own
strength
toji used the jujutsu knowledge from the
xenon family and turned it against
sorcerers this earned him the title the
sorcerer killer during the star plasma
vessel escort mission
an assignment given to the two strongest
sorcerers by master tengen
toji was hired by the time vessel
association to assassinate the girl
toji was able to completely derail the
escort through a series of tactical
moves over the course of a few days
he wore down the escort team and lured
them into a false sense of security
before he abruptly made his move
this allowed him to successfully pull
off a surprise attack on a user of the
prestigious six eyes an ocular jutsu
that grants god-like perception
toji took full advantage of his lack of
cursed energy
making him the perfect assassin thanks
to his status as an invisible man the
culmination
of all toji's talents allowed him to
successfully defeat the star plasma
vessel's escort team and assassinate the
girl completing his assignment while
nearly killing both
of jujutsu high's most blessed sorcerers
in the process
toji was only defeated when he pitted
his pure physical prowess against the
literally
infinite power of the awakened limitless
technique wheeled by seru gojo
even in the face of this power toji was
able to create clever ways to combat the
abilities of the limitless that were
known to the xenon family only the
secret hollow purple technique was
powerful enough to put down toji once
and for
all yuki sukumo another special grade
sorcerer found that toji was the only
case where a heavenly restriction has
eradicated someone's cursed energy
completely by eliminating all cursed
energy
toji's body was sharpened to the point
where he developed a resistance to
curses and was able to detect them with
his highly
refined five senses this also allowed
him to dominate and utilize a cursed
spirit capable of his strong wide
arsenal of weapons
yuki considered him to be truly
superhuman and told suguru that he
shouldn't be ashamed to have lost to him
in a fight when resurrected by
granny ogami's seance technique toji's
body was able to override her technique
and acted purely on fighting instinct at
the side of his out of control rampage
toji killed ogami with a single blow and
nearly beat grey2 sorcerer takuma ino to
death with his bare hands
completely alone and absolutely
dominated him dagon was a powerful curse
that maki and grade 1 sorceress kento
nanami and naobito zenin were not able
to defeat together
in comparison toji made exercising dagon
look effortless
cementing his own status too undeniably
on the level of there of a special grade
shortly after toji confronted megami and
the latter compared toji to a fully
realised maki he also recognised toji as
a monster
capable of taking out a special grade
cursed spirit and assessed his shikagami
were no match for him
if toji had not chosen to sacrifice
himself megami too would have just been
another victim of toji's rampage
the abilities of toji for shigeru unlike
any known case in the world
toji possesses no cursed energy at all
his heavenly restriction eliminated
curse energy from his body completely
this makes toji undetectable to jujutsu
sorcerers
making him capable of moving through
barriers undetected or even sneaking
past the six eyes
this aided his unpredictability and
caused others to underestimate him based
purely on his cursed energy
toji fujiguro's heavenly restriction the
trade of fatoji's complete lack of curse
energy is his immense physical prowess
while it has been noted that several
people have had heavenly restrictions
that bring their cursed energy to a
normal human's level
toji is the only case where it has
erased the person's energy completely by
eliminating
all curse energy toji's body became
sharpened to a point where his five
senses reached his
pinnacle and he could freely interact
with curses
granny ogami summons the information of
toji's body for her seance technique
however she's unable to control him
because his heavenly gifted body
overwrites her grandchild's soul
information
furthermore his body doesn't take up
cursed energy allowing toji to be
resurrected for an unprecedented amount
of time
toji has a cursed spirit that can store
a high number of different objects
within its body
this allows toji to store his weapons as
well as freely interchange them by
putting them into the curse or taking
them out of its mouth
additionally the curse can shrink itself
within its own body allowing toji to
ingest it so people can't detect the
cursed energy it emits the inventory
curse contains toji's entire wide
arsenal
including his cursed tools a chain and
even a swarm of fly heads toji can use
as chef grenades
suguru attempted to absorb this curse to
stop toji's access to weapons but it was
able to reject him
displaying toji's uncanny control over
it toji used a normal katana to stab
gojo through his back during his initial
surprise attack on the escort team
using a non-cursed tool allowed him to
stab sudoru without being detected
today used a standard handgun to
suddenly shoot rico amani the star
plasma vessel in the head and killer he
also fires several bullets at suguru
while avoiding his rainbow dragon
toji used a small combat knife with a
thin blade and dual wield alongside his
inverted spear of heaven to cut down
sardaro finished off the slashing flurry
and stabbing him in the forehead with a
knife one of toji's primary curse tools
was
the large japanese broadsword with the
fur tsuba and a dark handle
coupled with toji's superhuman strength
this weapon was able to cut through
several of sugaru's curses
including the rainbow dragon which had
the hardest skin among all of his curses
and the crazy thing is that this weapon
was only worth 500 000 yen the inverted
spear of heaven is a special grey tool
with the ability to completely nullify
curse techniques on contact it does so
by using an imbued curse technique
fueled by a foreign cursed energy he
used this to force the stoppage of the
infinity technique completely bypassing
the nearly impenetrable limitless
toji also connected this dagger to a
chain to create a
kusa rigama like weapon allowing him to
use the inverted spear of heaven from a
long range
playful cloud is a special grey tool
that embodies pure and solid power which
he took from maki zenon after he was
resurrected
in toji's hands the three section staff
reflected his incredible physical
strength making a weapon capable of
destroying even dagon's hardest
shikagami with a single blow by rubbing
it together toji sharpened playful cloud
turning it into a deadly stabbing weapon
he used it to stag dagon repeatedly
through the head until the special grade
was exercised
anyway guys i hope you all enjoyed the
video really love toji and his whole
character design i think that he was
fleshed out really well in the manga and
it'd be awesome when we get to see
the goat animated in the second season
of jjk sometime soon hopefully
if you guys are new around here be sure
to hit that sub button because something
insane like 95
of the people that watch my vids aren't
subscribed so hit that if you can
also remember to like the video and
leave a comment down below and let me
know who you want to see
feature next but for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and i'll
see you all in a bit
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign